إذا كنت تعلم أنني تعرفت على الكثير من
القادة الأجانب ، واسمحوا لي أن أخبركم ،
على عكس
قائدنا ، أنهم في صدارة لعبتهم ،
فهؤلاء مثل فريق التمثيل المركزي ،
لا يوجد أحد يمكنه أن
يلعب الدور في هوليوود ، كل هوليوود
لا يمكن لأحد أن يلعبه  دور الرئيس الحادي عشر
للصين ، لا أحد يستطيع أن يلعب الدور ، إنه
شخص شرس ،
بوتين شرس ، إنهم أذكياء ، كما تعلمون في
كثير من الأحيان ، سأقول إن شخصًا ما
ذكيًا وستنتقل الأخبار المزيفة ، اتصل
بالرئيس شي ذكي
إنه يحكم بمكواة  قبضة 1.5 مليار
شخص ، نعم ، أقول إنه ذكي ، ألا
تقول إنه ذكي ،
وأنا حقًا تربطني علاقة رائعة
به ،
ثم طرحت عليه سؤالًا ، فقلت
الرئيس إنه رئيس مدى الحياة
بالمناسبة ، لذا أدعوه الملك الأول  قال الملك
، لكنني لست ملكًا ، قلت إنك
لي أنت رئيس مدى الحياة إنه
نفس الشيء